what's going on everybody and welcome to
part 4 of the Python 3 basics tutorial
in this tutorial we are making a
tic-tac-toe in order with Python in
order to learn the Python 3 basics where
we left off we've got our you know our
our grid that is gonna be our
tic-tac-toe sort of game map and now
what we want to do is visualize for the
user a way for them to to be able to say
hey I want to play on such-and-such row
in such-and-such column or you know such
as such column or such-and-such row and
so on so there's a few options that we
have from easy to hard that we could do
but basically we probably want to have
like numbers or letters at the top and
then maybe numbers or letters on the
side so one a or one one or or or
whatever so so the first thing is like
what if we just wanted to like print
some numbers up at the top how might we
how might we get around doing that well
one option is super simple we could just
simply do like a print statement and say
0 1 2 now it's not gonna be lined just
right so let's just run it really quick
ok so we probably really just need one
space here let's run it again and that
appears to be pretty well aligned so if
you wanted to move 0 1 2 you know for
the actual row name all right so there's
be a column name you could specify that
column by 0 1 or 2 now what about on the
other side like how would we do it over
here
right because in it's in this print row
that we would need the number well
there's a variety of things that we
could do so one of the ways a basic
programmer might do this is with a
starting with like some sort of counter
so you could say count equals zero and
then in print you can continue to just
print many things at a time so print row
well you could instead prints we could
print count comma row so this will print
count add a space and then print the row
so
for example if I just run this now it's
you know all zeros and we can see our
top thing is messed up so let's add look
probably two more spaces there that
should do it
yeah so now how can we get count to go
up well all we need to do is do count
and you could say count equals count
plus one that's one way you could do it
and so we could run that real quick and
see okay 0 1 2 on that left-hand side
for the each each row the other option
is a slightly more condensed plus equals
one this does the exact same thing as
count equals count plus one okay pretty
cool now this is not really the best way
to do it in terms of you know being the
best Python programmer you could be but
it does get the job done that said
Python comes with a huge assortment of
what are called built-in functions so
let's do Python 3 built-in functions and
let's just click on that that first one
and you can see here there's quite a few
built-in functions each one does
something special from abs which is just
absolute value all the way down to I'm
gonna skip important just do zip zip is
a way to at least usually what you do a
zip is combine a couple of lists we can
we I don't we might use zip later but
anyways all of these are super useful
but these built-in functions most of
them are written in Python and so you
don't have to know them so like I was
saying before built-in functions are
like more tools that you can add to your
tool set but do you need them no you
don't have to learn every single one but
once in a while just like I said before
you know you might want to come in and
look at the built-in function just get
reminded at what all is available to you
and maybe try to learn a new one once in
a while or something and there's really
there is a lot here but it doesn't take
long to learn what all of these do so
anyway one of the built-in ones that
we're going to use is enumerate we could
click on it we can learn more but
basically all it does is it iterates as
you iterate over
something innumerate returns both the
index value and the value of the thing
you're iterating over now an index value
is the thing in a list so two let's just
write it out first I think I'm trying to
say which would be better I don't know
if I'm gonna write it out or not I think
I will and they maybe delete it all
that's probably will do so so you can do
four count comma row in enumerate game
and then let's get rid of this count
here and then we'll get rid of this
count here so now we're gonna iterate
over the rows in game now iterating now
what is each row in game remember each
row is this little bit this bit in this
bit and then you could iterate over the
values in the rows as well and I could
show that in a moment but first let's go
ahead and print this one out as you can
see we have the same thing so one thing
to take note of is initially your index
value starts at zero everything in
programming starts at zero not this is
Row 1 2 3 this is row 0 Rho 1 Rho 2 so
sometimes you'll hear me refer to things
as the first if element because it's not
the first element it's the first tooth
element so or the zeroeth element and so
on so sometimes I'll make those
distinctions just because it can
sometimes get confusing but it really
most that time I refer to something I'm
referring to its index value so so those
are at least that's one of the built-in
functions in in Python so just to show
you what I meant to sometimes this stuff
can be hard to visualize at first I'm
sure many of you guys already have it
you understand as you iterate over the
rows okay cool I've got that well but
you also could iterate over the elements
in each because this is a list of lists
so when we do a for something in that
list of lists you've got list 1 and then
the list 2 so when you iterate over a
list of lists the first thing that
you're iterating over is the lid
but if you you could take that further
and iterate over the items in those
lists with just another four so as a
quick note if you want to leave
something in your code or write
something in your code you can do what's
called a comment a single line comment
is a pound or a hashtag depending on
when you were born so so anyways that's
how you comment something out a comment
is just for people reading your code you
to take notes the programming language
doesn't care what you put in there it
doesn't have to be Python 3 syntax you
can put anything in a comment so that's
a single line comment if you want to
make multi-line comments you can use
triple quotes multi-line comments okay
that's a multi-line comment so anyways
now that we've commented those things
out we won't see them anymore so now
let's instead say for item in row
because remember row being a temporary
value right now it's the store of like
for example this or this it's all zeros
but you could iterate over them and
print item and as you can see it's just
a bunch of zeros nothing special
anyways that's I think that's a good
spot for us to stop I am going to now
get rid of our comment get rid of this
get rid of this and this will now throw
an error so I'm gonna get rid of that
and let me make sure everything looks
correct it does okay so now what I'm
gonna do is also at some point we
probably should make this like a b c or
something like that i think that starts
to make a little more sense but you can
do whatever you want I just think that's
probably less likely to cause problems
later but we'll talk about it so anyways
I'm gonna leave me here and now moving
forward we've at least got a game map so
I can run it again we now know a user
could say okay I want to play a 0 or B 2
so if we typed in you know it's like if
we allow input from the
and they say baby - we can all agree
that's going to be that spot right there
so what we need to start being able to
do is use our programming to somehow
manipulate that exact spot on the on the
game board both so we can do analysis
with our programming to decide hey has
anybody won
can they even move there but also to
visualize it for the user after they've
made the move so that's going to require
indexing and and might as well cover
slices at the same time so that's what
we're gonna talk about in the next video
if you have questions comments concerns
whatever feel free to even below join
the discord otherwise I will see you
guys and girls in the next video